dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here this
paper reveals us a fundamental
difference between how humans and
machines learn you are given a videogame
with no instructions you start playing
it and the only information you get is a
line of text when you successfully
finish the game that's it so far so good
this is relatively easy to play because
the visual cues are quite clear the pink
blob looks like an adversary and what
the spikes do is also self-explanatory
this is easy to understand so we can
finish the game in less than a minute
easy
now let's play this whoa what is
happening even empty space looks like as
if it were a solid tile I am not sure if
I can finish this version of the game at
least not in a minute for sure so what
is happening here is that some of the
artwork of the objects has been masked
out as a result this version of the game
is much harder to play for humans so far
this is hardly surprising and if that
would be it this wouldn't have been a
very scientific experiment however this
is not the case so to proceed from this
point we will try to find what makes
humans learn so efficiently but not by
changing everything at once but by
trying to change and measure only one
variable at a time so how about this
version of the game this is still
manageable
since the environment remains the same
only the objects we interact with have
been masked through trial and error we
can find out the mechanics of the game
what about reversing the semantics
spikes now become tasty ice cream and
the shiny gold conceals an enemy that
eats us very apt I have to say again
with this the problem suddenly became
more difficult for humans as we need
some trial and error to find out the
rules after putting together several
other masking strategies they measured
the amount of time the number of deaths
and interactions that were required to
finish the level I will draw your
attention mainly to the blue lines which
show which variable cost how much
degredation to the performance of humans
main piece of insight is not only that
these different visual cues throw off
humans but it tells us variable by
variable and also by how much an
important insight here is that
highlighting important objects and
visual consistency are key so what about
the machines how our learning algorithms
affected these are the baseline results
adding math semantics barely an issue
masked object identities this sounds
quite hard right
barely an issue masked platforms and
ladders barely an issue this is a
remarkable property of learning
algorithms as they don't only think in
terms of visual cues but in terms of
mathematics and probabilities removing
similarity information throws the
machines off a bit which is
understandable because the same objects
may appear as if they were completely
different there is more analysis on this
in the paper so make sure to have a look
so what are the conclusions here humans
are remarkably good at reusing knowledge
and reading and understanding visual
cues however if the visual cues become
more cryptic their performance
drastically decreases when machines
start playing the game at first they
have no idea which character they
control how gravity works or how to
defeat enemies or that keys are required
to open doors
however they learn these tricky problems
and games much easier and quicker
because these mind-bending changes as
you remember are barely an issue note
that you can play the original and the
obfuscated versions on the author's
website as well also note that we really
have only scratched the surface here the
paper contains a lot more insights so it
is the perfect time to nourish your mind
with a paper make sure to click it in
the video description and give it a read
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time